now the log jam over healthcare is one
reason some Republican lawmakers want to
keep working without a summer break not
everybody thinks that's a good idea
members have fewer than 15 legislative
days left on this summer schedule
they're supposed to leave for Washington
for the whole month of August even
though they haven't passed any of the
big pieces of legislation on the GOP
agenda Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
with a new push to change the
congressional calendar Nancy good
morning good morning you know this
tradition of an August congressional
recess dates back to a time before air
conditioning when members of Congress
had to get out of town because it was
just too painful here in the nation's
capitol but now some Republicans are
starting to worry about the heat they'll
get back home if they leave for the
entire month of August without
fulfilling some major promises we should
be locked on the House floor until we
get some things done pause for a big
congressional scheduling change are
getting louder I'm ready to work through
hours we cannot be taking a vacation or
a break in August if we haven't done the
people's work I can tell you what if you
did a vote out there in the real world
they would vote for us to stay here and
get their work done Georgia senator
David Perdue is one of many Republicans
pushing to do away with the annual
five-week break in a letter to Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell Perdue and nine
colleagues point out there are only 31
working days until the end of the fiscal
year in that time Republicans want to
pass a health care bill tackle tax
reform plus Congress needs to fund the
government and raise the debt limit the
gridlock up here is not understood by
people back home nor is it going to be
towering Maine Republicans susan collins
has served in Congress for more than two
decades why does Congress go home so
often in for such a long period of time
we've learned so much when we do go home
it gives us the chance to spend extended
periods of time
with our constituents Congress is
actually on track to spend more days in
session this year than the 20-year
average as Republican leaders try to
make the most of their control of
Congress and the White House look if
time were the only consideration
absolutely staying through August would
make sense congressional scholar norm
Ornstein says so far Republicans don't
have much to show for the extra work
days they don't have a consensus of the
votes and they refuse to try and broaden
that base to find consensus by bringing
in Democrats if Republicans want to
stick around they're going to need
Democratic support because big changes
to the Congressional calendar require
approval from leadership of both sides
and Nora Democrats probably aren't eager
to give Republicans more time to try to
enact their agenda gonna be an
interesting week there Nancy thank you
so much